now i said we wanted to explore units of
measurement here a little bit okay so
what we're going to do is over your next
column okay this is height in
centimeters
i'd like us to calculate height in
meters
right now why might you do that well for
instance suppose you wanted to calculate
say bmis the bmi formula needs height in
meters not in centimeters so that might
be a reason why you convert okay
so
how many centimeters are there in a
meter how many centimeters there are 100
centimeters right because you know it's
centi like century etc right so that's a
hundred in one meter okay so to go from
centimeters two meters one point
i'm going to have to
divide by
a hundred right that'll turn a hundred
into one okay do you remember did we
actually have a look at what's a symbol
for division
it's the slash right
like that
okay so
hit equals to start your formula
go to the left that's your height there
and now divide by a
hundred
and it's 1.65 as you'd expect that's
1.65 meters
so
division is this this slash symbol yeah
okay so did you just do that
yeah okay divide by 100 and now if i
copy that cell i copy the formula that's
there you can go all the way down
um just ctrl c
and then ctrl v there you go okay so i
press equals
equals and then i'll show you i'll show
you the formula there you go
okay
got it there yeah and then and then how
did you make all once so copy and paste
it all the way down copy the cell and
then paste them or you can drag the
corner do you remember how to drag the
corner so i don't do shift and run down
no that's just going to select them you
want to paste into them okay
okay
so now
i've got high centimeters i've got
height in meters but interestingly
enough even though we are a metric
society
people still talk especially with regard
to height we still talk in imperial
right so we say you know something like
i'm five foot whatever right or or six
foot whatever or whatever your height
might be okay
so how would i go from these into
the height in feet
how would i do it
okay
now i'm going to go to google and say um
what is one
uh let's see one foot in
centimeters
okay one foot in centimeters and it
tells me
that one foot is 30.48 centimeters let
me write that down that's important
okay now inches is not very helpful um
yet because um they're going to be
another unit of comparison still okay so
i've got one foot
equals 30. i should root them the other
way around
one foot
equals 30.48 centimeters
so can someone give me a suggestion
for how we're going to write a formula
for this column
okay so i've got centimeters there
and i'm going to divide by this 30.48 if
i divide it by 100 it'll give me meters
but if i divide by 30.48 it should give
me feet
okay now you look at that does that
sound reasonable
five foot something it does sound
reasonable so we've done it right and
again you can copy that and paste it
down okay all the way to the bottom
this scenario is interesting to me it's
useful
but it's not natural because if you say
to someone how tall are you you don't
expect them to say i'm five point four
one three three eight five eight feet
tall right instead we say i'm
five foot
nine five foot three
what's that second number when you say
five
foot inches nine aha okay so what we're
kind of inserting in there is that that
second number
is inches okay so how do i how do i get
that out of there this is tricky okay
so let me show you how to get it out
here's what we're going to do
the first thing i want is i want just
the number of feet so for example here i
just want five here i just want four i
just want uh six and so on okay so we're
going to do a few cool formulas here
okay so this is the feet only
right so how am i going to do this
basically what you want is you want some
rounding right like you see 5.41 it
rounds down to five so that gives you
the number of feet okay
five point uh
four point one that also rounds down to
four that's okay
but if you just do rounding on this
what's going to happen
it's gonna go up to six but no one says
oh i'm six foot minus
minus one right you say i'm five foot
eleven even though it's really close to
six right so what we want is for it to
round down always round down no matter
how close it is to the number above so
if you wanted to round down
excel is very common sense with how it
names its things you write down
round
down
okay
so i said equals round down what happens
if you put a space
yeah try not to put in spaces it sort of
says often often it will it will break
on you if you put in spaces because it's
expecting something there and it's not
there okay
so i'm going to open up brackets
yeah i haven't finished it so what do i
want to round down i want to round down
the height in feet so we'll go over to
that so that's d2
and then you might notice it says here
you have the number you want to round
down and then a number of digits they
mean decimal places okay how many
decimal places do i want
i don't want any decimal places i just
want the five
right
yeah that's that's what i meant to say
right so therefore you go comma zero
okay so what's it doing it's rounding
down this cell to zero decimal places
you hit enter
and you get five well no big deal you
expected that
but if we copy that formula down into
the ones below
what do you get
does it work
yeah it works look even in this case
here five foot five point nine feet
right it has rounded down to five anyway
okay
all right
so now my task is i have to work out
how many inches there are left okay
how do i do that